[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten
guten abend
man muss auch das gute sehen das gelang
heute sogar dem grund skeptischen
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach die korona lage stabilisiert
sich langsam schrieb der neue minister
und anlass sind für ihn diese zahlen die
inzidenz singt seit zwei wochen wird er
kam auf aktuell 3
189,2 zum rückgang der fallzahlen kommen
fortschritte bei den booster impfungen
seit ende november inzwischen sind
19,8 millionen deutsche gewusst hat ziel
30 millionen grund zur entwarnung ist
das längst nicht weihnachten dürfte jede
leichte entspannung wieder aufbrauchen
und die omikron variante nimmt vater in
dieser situation startete heute die
impfkampagne für kinder von 5 bis 11
jahren
die stiko empfiehlt die impfung etwa für
kinder mit vorerkrankungen sibylle
bassler berichtet aus bayern
bis zuletzt war es eine zitterpartie
kommt der impfstoff für kinder ab fünf
jahren heute oder nicht dann um 12 uhr
30 aufatmen in der augsburger
kinderarztpraxis von dr lang 400 dosen
bei jahren tag für kinder sind da
zu der impfung kam jetzt kurz auf knapp
die patienten kommen gleich eine halbe
stunde arbeitszeit geklagt davor lag ein
intensives arbeits wochenende per praxis
app wurden eltern der kleinen patienten
informiert das feedback war riesig das
praxisteam musste viele fragen am
telefon beantworten was sind denn die
nebenwirkungen auf was müssen wir achten
ob sie vorerkrankungen haben ist auch
sehr wichtig also die eltern haben schon
etwas angst wollen aber doch die kinder
impfen weiß doch mit den schulen
kindergärten zu lang ist über 200 kinder
wurden an einem tag von ihren eltern
angemeldet bis weihnachten sind alle
termine vergeben
die ersten impflinge sind am nachmittag
am start
[Musik]
und dann wird es ernst
der siebenjährige lorenzi ist als erster
junge dran
die kinder impfung ein herzensanliegen
des mediziners denn immer wieder sieht
er die folgen von corona gerade bei den
jüngsten
auch wieder ein normales leben führen
können tatsächlich empfiehlt die
ständige impfkommission die stiko die
impfung ab fünf jahren in erster linie
für kinder mit vorerkrankungen nicht
unbedingt für gesunde kinder da sagt die
aktuelle empfehlung der ständigen
impfkommission
dass wir noch nicht ausreichende daten
haben um das profil exakt zu verwerten
und erzielt ist daher noch nicht allen
kindern zu helfen
die stiko empfehlung hier in der praxis
scheint sie kaum wirkung zu zeigen
und wir haben euch die ganze darauf
gewartet dass er dann dass wir komplett
sind eigentlich und trinken sind moment
auch gedacht ist das richtige übersicht
da es keinen großen für uns entschieden
war es für ihn entschieden das war
komisch den einsetzenden zu lassen die
impfungen laufen nimmt zehn-minuten-takt
auch denner die kilian und lorenz sind
dran große diskussionen sagt ihre mutter
gab es nicht
dank lang damit auseinandersetzt schon
vorher dass wir uns hinten weil ich weiß
nicht was auch nicht von machen wird 40
kinder zwischen fünf und elf jahren hat
martin lang heute geimpft und morgen
geht es weiter bis zum jahresende will
er mindestens 400 kinder immunisiert
haben
und über die impfung für kleinere kinder
wollen wir sprechen mit der neuen
bundesfamilienministerin eine spiegel
show guten abend
vor spiegel noch liegt ja die
erwachsenen impfung ziemlich weit zurück
die impfquote bei den zweit impfungen
ist jedenfalls wirklich noch zu steigern
warum ist es nun nötig dass auch kleine
kleinere kinder geimpft werden ja also
ich glaube das ist eine große
erleichterung für die familien im land
die instanzen sind ja bei den kindern so
hoch wie nie zuvor seit beginn der
pandemie und da ist es jetzt schon gut
dass es eben die impf angebote auch für
familien gibt und kinder und dass sie
sich vor allen dingen auch informieren
und beraten lassen können es wird
durchaus angenommen diese möglichkeit
der impfung aber es gibt ja doch auch
eltern die wirklich verunsichert sind
die ständige impfkommission empfiehlt
die impfung eben nicht für alle kinder
ab fünf der hinweis auf noch nicht
ausreichende daten was etwaige
nebenwirkungen angeht hilft da vielen
eltern nicht die sind selbst mutter von
vier kindern die wegen sie das risiko ab
also zunächst mal gibt die stiko ja
schon eine orientierung also sie hat
sich dazu geäußert und ich glaube es ist
sehr wichtig dass diejenigen die sich
schon für eine impfung entschieden haben
sich jetzt impfen lassen können und alle
anderen die auch noch fragezeichen haben
oder sich beraten lassen können für die
es ist gut dass die länder und kommunen
und auch viele kinderarztpraxen jetzt
eine struktur aufgebaut haben dass es
bereits informationen gibt für die
familien damit sie für sich die richtige
entscheidung treffen und so hoffe ich
auch ihre kinder dann impfen lassen sie
hoffen dass aber es ist natürlich immer
eine risikoabwägung am ende deshalb
nochmal die nachfrage hätten sie sich
ein klareres wohnungen der stiko
gewünscht also zum einen finde ich schon
dass das eine orientierung gibt und zum
anderen ist es glaube ich auch wichtig
dass man über das was sich stücke hinaus
sagt jetzt einfach zur eigenen
kindererziehung zum eigenen kinderarzt
geht oder sich bei mobilen impf teams
oder bei anderen stellen eben die
entsprechenden infos und die beratung
holt es ist glaube ich sehr wichtig dass
es jetzt einfach los geht und auch eine
große erleichterung für viele familien
die sich schon entschieden haben und
diesen schritt jetzt gehen wollen ein
argument hört man immer auch von ihrer
kollegin im kabinett der
bildungsministerin die schulen sollen
dadurch offen bleiben können besser
offen bleiben wenn die kinder geimpft
sind jetzt war es ja im letzten jahr so
dass die kinder eben zuhause saßen kein
unterricht keine freunde kein sport und
haben im grunde die opfer für den schutz
der erwachsenen gebracht ist es jetzt
nicht vor spiegel eigentlich wieder so
weil sich die erwachsenen nicht
ausreichend impfen lassen impfen wir die
kinder also zunächst man geht ja auch
für die erwachsenen weiterhin und da
kann ich nur appellieren sich impfen zu
lassen sich vor allen dingen boostern zu
lassen auch das bietet ja wirklich einen
sehr guten schutz aber gleichzeitig geht
es natürlich auch darum dass wir die
kinder und jugendlichen schützen
und da geht es nicht nur um kitas und
schulen der ganze alltag von kindern ist
ja ins rutschen geraten mit der pandemie
und ich glaube schon dass eine impfung
hier auch ein wichtiger beitrag sein
kann zum einen ganze familien alle
generationen in den familien zu schützen
aber zum anderen auch einen teil dazu
beizutragen dass wir hoffentlich über
viele impfungen diese pandemie auch in
die knie zwingen können und den kindern
ein stück ihres alltags zurückgeben
können eine allgemeine impfpflicht
könnte im nächsten frühjahr kommen
darauf bereitet auch der neue kanzler
olaf scholz die bevölkerung vor wird
sollte sie dann auch für kinder gelten
die debatte halte ich noch für zu
verfrüht wir sehen jetzt dass rund jeder
zweite jugendliche in deutschland
bereits einmal geimpft ist und jetzt
geht es für die kinder los und die
entsprechenden dosen sind ja bestellt 24
millionen also jetzt soll es erst mal
losgehen für die familien die schon
entschieden sind und die ich darauf auch
schon gewartet haben und jetzt ferne
ihre kinder impfen lassen das war auch
wenn sie sagen verfrüht sie schließen
dass auch nicht aus dass es kommen
könnte naja das infektionsgeschehen ist
ja sehr dynamisch das haben wir in
dieser pandemie gelernt dass sich
situation auch leider schnell verändern
können und für mich ist es wichtig dass
das gesundheitssystem nicht an seine
grenzen kommt das ist eine ganz wichtige
richtschnur in der pandemie dennoch ich
halte die debatte jetzt auf kinder
bezogen für verfrüht jetzt sollten wir
erstmal loslegen und die familien die
sich schon entschieden haben denen auch
schnell ein impfangebot machen können
das ist dann vielleicht auch eine erste
lehre der politik keine versprechungen
mehr machen wir danken sehr dankeschön
frau spiegel danke an die neue
familienministerin dankeschön
das gespräch haben wir kurz vor der
sendung aufgezeichnet jan gegen eine
allgemeine impfpflicht und andere
staatliche corona maßnahmen ging am
wochenende in vielen städten menschen
auf die straße vielerorts angemeldet und
friedlich an anderer stelle nicht
genehmigt und mit hoher
gewaltbereitschaft im thüringischen
greiz etwa wurden 14 polizeibeamte
verletzt gegen die nachrichten
plattformen telegramm über deren offenen
kanäle hass und gewalt aufrufe
verbreitet werden will
bundesinnenministerium felser nun
schritte prüfen politik und
sicherheitsexperten fürchten eine
radikalisierung des protests im
sächsischen meißen waren die instanzen
in den vergangenen wochen auf
bundesweiten höchstständen mittlerweile
fallen die zahlen trotzdem drohen
weitere maßnahmen über alltag und
protest im hotspot meißen franziska
wunderlich
die tische eingedeckt das besteck
geputzt doch das bestellen von katrin
herzog ist leer die nächsten tage sind
sehr verhalten also es gibt ganz ganz
ganz viele bestellungen storniert worden
sind die leute bleiben im augenblick
auch alle zu hause weil es gibt immer
irgendwo in irgendeiner familie jemanden
ja nicht geimpft und nicht genesen ist
schon ihr urgroßvater bewirtete in der
alten schmiede seine gäste dass ihr nun
aufgrund der pandemie und erneut
verschärften corona regeln in sachsen
wieder eine schließung droht macht der
wirtin zu schaffen
aber dieses auf und ab nicht planen
können nicht wissen wie es weiter geht
also es ist für eigentlich für eine
firma nicht zu händen der landkreis
meisten schockte die republik in der
vergangenen woche mit einer inzidenz von
fast 2900 mittlerweile ist sie auf
1535 gesunken doch sinkt sie nicht unter
1.500 müssen die gastronomiebetriebe ab
donnerstag ganz schließen bislang
durften sie bis 20 uhr öffnen selbst das
war schon für manche eine nicht
nachvollziehbar das ist so hoffe auch
dass die gaststätten um abschließen
müssen habe ich eigentlich völliges
unverständnis
na ja aus meiner persönlichen sicht ist
es ist es richtig das so zu machen das
problem ist natürlich dass die menschen
irgendwie in diese versprechungen der
politik geglaubt haben und letztes jahr
wurde ja gesagt sobald impfungen zu
nehmen würde man solche maßnahmen nicht
mehr ergreifen von daher hat man da
wieder dieses misstrauens problem in die
politik den frust spüre man auch im
landratsamt also eine sehr sehr
schlechte stimmung und wenn ja soll ich
jetzt bezogen auf eine ganz
nachvollziehbare regelung auch noch
gaststätten geschlossen werden entzieht
man den leuten natürlich ihre
existenzgrundlage also den worten dass
die inzidenz 'nen vor wenigen tagen
einen negativrekord erreichten und nun
wieder sinken erklärt der meister
landrat mit melde rückständen die
nachgearbeitet wurden dennoch bleiben
die infektionszahlen auf hohem niveau
ganz im gegensatz zur impfquote die
liegt derzeit bei etwa 55 prozent in
sidenten ist lediglich die infektion als
solches ist keine erkrankung deswegen
halte ich es schlüssiger wenn wir ein
zusammenhang herstellt zwischen einer
tatsächlich auftretenden erkrankung
ihrer schwere und dann kommt der
erkrankte ins krankenhaus oder
vielleicht sogar auf die fdp es in
diesem zusammenhang den gibt's das wir
überwiegend zu 90% ungeimpfte patienten
haben auch auf der ets und das ist für
mich der beleg doch fakten wie diesen
verschließt sich mancher in sachsen aber
auch in bayern baden württemberg und
thüringen gibt es proteste gegen
impfkampagnen und corona maßnahmen
proteste bei denen am wochenende auch
polizisten und journalisten angegriffen
und verletzt wurden ja ich fürchte dass
ich einige gruppierungen tatsächlich
noch weiter radikalisieren und aus dass
aus der gewalt womöglich auch anschläge
gezielter natur erwachsen das ist ja
nicht mehr auszuschließen insofern kann
durchaus daraus
erwachsen aber auf der anderen seite
wird man sicherlich auch versuchen
müssen eben die spreu vom weizen zu
trennen das heißt die besorgten
bürgerinnen und bürger wirklich davon zu
überzeugen dass man mit solchen personen
nicht gemeinsam auf die straße geht und
auch am heutigen abend gab es wieder
vielerorts proteste so wie hier in
saalfeld diese verliefen weitestgehend
friedlich
wir bleiben noch beim thema corona und
schauen in den nachrichten jetzt ins
nachbarland österreich gründe der pause
dort sind nach dreiwöchigem harten
lockdown viele geschäfte und restaurants
in fast allen regionen für geimpfte und
genesene wieder geöffnet die inzidenz
konnte zwar deutlich gesenkt werden
trotzdem aber ist die regierung in wien
in sorge vor einer weiteren welle
womöglich im januar in den geschäften
war der andrang recht groß der
handelsverband hofft auf verstärkte
weihnachtseinkäufe die 2g nachweise
werden stichprobenartig überprüft bei
verstößen drohen kunden geldstrafen von
bis zu 500 euro den geschäftsinhabern
von bis zu 3600 euro
die gesundheitsminister von bund und
ländern beraten morgen über ein
bundeseinheitliches ende der test licht
für drei mal geimpfte
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
hatte sich dafür ausgesprochen auch als
anreiz für die booster impfung wer diese
hat ist in baden württemberg
niedersachsen und rheinland-pfalz
bereits von der test pflichtbereich
befreit
unterdessen sind immer mehr gefälschte
impfpässe im umlauf nach zdf recherchen
haben sich die verfahren wegen
gefälschter nachweise in den letzten
wochen verdoppelt von rund 3000 auf über
6000 in den niederlanden haben sich rund
neun monate nach der parlamentswahl die
vier bisherigen regierungsparteien auf
einen neuen koalitionsvertrag geeinigt
es war die längste regierungsbildung in
der geschichte des landes
ministerpräsident rutte seit elf jahren
im amt wird auch die neue regierung
führen
israels ministerpräsident benjamin
positiv bewertet mit kronprinz scheich
bin sajed hatte er in abu dhabi über
kooperationsmöglichkeiten im handel bei
technologie und tourismus beraten israel
und die emirate hatten ihre beziehungen
erst im vergangenen jahr unter
vermittlung der usa normalisiert beide
länder eint die sorge über das iranische
atomprogramm
nach den g 7 staaten hat auch die
europäische union in der ukraine krise
eine deutliche warnung an russland
gerichtet jeder angriff auf die ukraine
werde hohe wirtschaftliche kosten für
russland haben sanktionen würden geprüft
erklärte der eu außenbeauftragte borel
nach beratungen der eu außenminister in
brüssel diese billigten außerdem
einstimmig strafmaßnahmen gegen eine
russische seltene truppe wegen
menschenrechtsverletzungen in der
ukraine syrien und in libyen moskau
weist den vorwurf der angriffs planung
gegen die ukraine seit wochen zurück
5 tage im amt hat der neue
finanzminister christian lindner schon
ordentlich auf die pauke gehauen anders
kann man es nicht nennen denn es geht um
60 milliarden dieser hatte es lindner
dem kabinett heute vorgelegt sollen per
nachtragshaushalt umgeschichtet werden
und neuen spielraum schaffen für
investitionen in klimaschutz und
digitalisierung lindner selbst nennt es
einen booster für die volkswirtschaft
womit er im bild bleibt denn es geht um
kredite die eigentlich zur bewältigung
der korona krise genehmigt war für
andere grenzt das ganze deshalb an
trickserei klaus brodbeck so manches
hier ist noch neu die regierung sowieso
auch wie neue regierende neuerdings
loben was sie noch vor kurzem heftig
kritisiert haben gut zu beobachten beim
neuen finanzminister christian lindner
und der nachtragshaushalt opposition war
gestern ja meine damen meine herren das
bundeskabinett hat heute
den regierungsentwurf des zweiten
nachtrags zum bundeshaushalts
2021 beschlossen das ist ein signal
unserer handlungsfähigkeit und es ist
ausdruck von gestaltungswillen darum
gibt es 240 milliarden neue schulden hat
der bundestag dieses jahr wegen der
korona krise genehmigt 60 milliarden
mehr als nötig über die die regierung
trotzdem kredite aufnehmen und das gilt
in den klima vor stecken will der damit
deutlich an wächst auf über 76
milliarden ein sogenanntes
sondervermögen bekannt auch als
schattenhaushalt geschaffen noch von der
grohe bereits im vergangenen jahr und
aufs schärfste damals kritisiert von
richtig auch der fdp
der bundesrechnungshof hat uns ins
stammbuch geschrieben das zitat der
zweite nachtragshaushalt beeinträchtigt
wesentliche
verfassungsgrundsätze will ehrlichkeit
fälligkeit wahrheit und klarheit ein
staatsrechtler der über alle
parteigrenzen hinweg
anerkannt ist hat ebenfalls festgestellt
dass dieser bundeshaushalt
verfassungswidrig ist die haben eine
fiskalische vorbildfunktion für andere
in europa und deshalb müssen wir weiter
der stabilitätsanker der europäischen
union der wirtschafts und währungsunion
bleiben deshalb dürfen wir nicht mehr
schulden machen als überhaupt nur
notwendig doch es geht nicht nur um
schulden sondern um solche die zur
bewältigung der korona krise gemacht
werden sollten tatsächlich aber soll das
geliehene geld breit investiert werden
es kommt zu ungewohnten allianzen wäre
christian lindner zu einer opposition
wurde ganz laut verfassungsbruch
schreiben und genau das ist ja das was
er gerade macht und die entscheidende
frage ist doch dass er vermeiden will
dass wir endlich eine gerechte
steuerreform haben wir können im
augenblick mehr geld ausgeben mehr
schulden aufnehmen ausnahmen von der
schuldenbremse mache allein aus einem
grund wegen der korona folgen man will
das geld aber jetzt nutzen um
digitalisierung und klimaschutzprojekte
damit zu finanzieren
das passt bei dem engen rahmen die die
verfassung setzt damit nicht zusammen
und deshalb überlegen wir auch nach
karlsruhe zeugen die union kritisiert
als opposition was sie noch in der
regierung selbst schon mal beschlossen
hatte sport vom ex-partner ich habe die
cdu csu muss erst noch verarbeiten dass
sie nicht mehr regieren sondern jetzt in
der opposition sind und von daher bin
ich sehr nachsichtig mit dieser
opposition gerade kurz vor weihnachten
opposition und so viele rollen neu zu
definieren weitere überraschungen nicht
ausgeschlossen
kentucky ist ein kleiner us-bundesstaat
im herzen einer streng religiösen region
gehört zum sogenannten bible belt die
menschen sind gottesfürchtig und manche
fragen sich nun warum schickt uns gott
eine solche katastrophe
am wochenende haben rund 30 tornados in
kentucky und mehreren anderen
bundesstaaten ganze landstriche
verwüstet ein ereignis das selbst für
die usa dass naturkatastrophen kennt
außergewöhnlich ist am schlimmsten traf
es wohl die kleinstadt mayfield hier
versuchen die einwohner auch an tag drei
nach der katastrophe zu retten was zu
retten ist während die diskussion
begonnen hat dass nicht gott für das
desaster verantwortlich ist sondern der
klimawandel benjamin daniel
seit zwei tagen ist joyce ununterbrochen
im einsatz ihr haus steht einige blöcke
weiter und blieb wie durch ein wunder
vom tornado verschont sie hilft ihren
nachbarn wo sie kann und ist damit eine
von unzähligen freiwilligen die mit
anpacken die stadt hält zusammen
es ist es praxis bricht mir das herz
wenn ich an die leute denken die es hart
getroffen hat das bringt mich um deshalb
will ich helfen das war überwältigend
wie viele andere freiwillige noch kamen
sie haben dann sogar welche nach hause
geschickt
die krankenschwester steht
stellvertretend für eine gemeinde die
sich trotz dieser schwer begreifbaren
katastrophe nicht unterkriegen lässt die
mieter sind wetterphänomene gewöhnt aber
solch einen tornado haben die menschen
hier noch nicht erlebt schon gar nicht
zu dieser jahreszeit
wissenschaftler und der us-präsident
sind davon überzeugt dass der
klimawandel für häufigere und
intensivere wetter extreme sorgt davon
will sie nichts wissen
es liegt alles in gottes hand ich glaube
nur an ihm nicht an die wissenschaft
in der ganzen stadt packen helferinnen
und helfer rund um die uhr mit an um
zunächst die trümmer wegzuräumen der
gouverneur spricht von der schlimmsten
tornado serie die den bundesstaat je
getroffen hat dass die zahl der
todesopfer in den betroffenen staaten
insgesamt wohl doch niedriger liegt als
zunächst befürchtet wird natürlich
positiv aufgenommen von den menschen
hier dennoch geht man allein im
bundesstaat kentucky weiterhin von mehr
als 60 toten aus
es ist verrückt den ort in dem du
aufgewachsen bist so zu sehen das ist
doch mein heimatort es ist überwältigend
man sieht ja überall die bilder aber
wenn man dann tatsächlich hier ist ist
das alles noch mal viel schlimmer es ist
verheerend es
gibt jetzt kein schwarz und weiß keine
demokraten oder republikaner wir sind
alle ein zu müssen unseren mitmenschen
jetzt einfach helfen
der tornado war das schlimmste was auch
greg jemals erlebt hat sie hatte glück
ihr haus wurde nur leicht beschädigt
anders als joyce ist sie sich sicher
ohne den klimawandel wäre das ausmaß der
katastrophe niemals so groß
sometimes it's raining es regnet
manchmal wenn es nicht regnen sollte
oder es schneit zu zeiten in denen es
normalerweise nicht schneit am freitag
waren es 27 grad das war heiss schwül
dabei haben wir doch dezember für unser
handeln zahlen wir jetzt den preis
die suche nach vermissten ist denn mir
fehlt noch immer nicht abgeschlossen die
hoffnung jetzt noch überlebende zu
finden schwindet allerdings von stunde
zu stunde
jetzt noch einmal nachrichten gründe der
pause
die von der sicherheitsbehörde bsi
ausgegebene höchste warnstufe rot wegen
möglicher schwerer hacker-angriffe hat
deutsche unternehmen zu diesem
wochenbeginn schwer beschäftigt viele
unternehmen haben ihre it
sicherheitsmaßnahmen hochgefahren
valerie haller inwiefern ist es denn
bereits zu den jetzt ganz konkret
befürchteten cyber angriffen gekommen
das lässt sich noch nicht sagen aber die
gute nachricht die sicherheitslücke
können unternehmen mit einem update
schließen die schlechte hacker können
sich in den it-systemen schon
eingenistet haben und später ihr unwesen
treiben wie groß die bedrohung also
tatsächlich ist wird man erst später
sehen alarmstufe rot die ruft die ig
sicherheitsbehörde eher selten aus doch
dieses mal geht es um eine server
software von java die sehr weit
verbreitet ist gelingt es einem
angreifer sich über die sicherheitslücke
zugriff auf einen rechner zu verschaffen
kann er dort die kontrolle übernehmen
und zb schadprogramme laufen lassen wir
sind große namen betroffen wie tesla zum
beispiel auch apple ist betroffen viele
große firmen und das heißt im
umkehrschluss dass einerseits die
hersteller betroffen sind andererseits
natürlich aber auch die endkunden die
dann dementsprechend die services nutzen
hacker entwickeln rasend schnell
schadprogramme 20 20 waren es 22 prozent
mehr als ein jahr zuvor der schaden
immens allein in deutschland geschätzte
2 123 milliarden euro firmen arbeiten
nun mit hochdruck daran das leck zu
stopfen infineon deutsche bank und
continental erklärten bisher keine
angriffe registriert zu haben doch
leider sagen experten machten nicht nur
die sicherheitsteams in unternehmen
gerade überstunden auch hacker die sich
für einen angriff in wochen oder monaten
bereit halten vielen dank valerie nach
frankfurt wir bleiben bei cyber
kriminalität im prozess gegen die
betreiber des sogenannten cyber bunkers
im rheinland-pfälzischen traben trarbach
sind die acht angeklagten zu
mehrjährigen haftstrafen verurteilt
worden der kopf der bande erhielt fünf
jahre und neun monate wegen
mitgliedschaft in einer kriminellen
vereinigung so das landgericht trier die
beschuldigten hatten in einem bunker
kriminellen eine plattform im so
genannten dark knight geboten etwa für
drogendeals falschgeld geschäfte und
cyber angriffe insgesamt ging es um fast
250.000 straftaten und viele millionen
euro die kaufprämie für elektroautos
wird um ein jahr verlängert bis ende
bis dahin erhalten die käufer von reinen
e-autos eine prämie von bis zu 9000 euro
plug-in-hybride werden mit maximal
6750 euro gefördert hintergrund der
verlängerung ist laut wirtschaft und
klimaschutz ministerium auch dass viele
bereits bestellte autos erst später
ausgeliefert werden können ab 2023 soll
die förderung dann neu aufgestellt
werden zum fussball da sind die
achtelfinal partien in der champions
league ausgelost worden und das gleich
zweimal weil die lostöpfe falsch befüllt
worden waren musste die ziehung
wiederholt werden der gegner von bayern
münchen heißt nicht wie zunächst
ausgelost atletico madrid sondern nun rb
salzburg
reibungslos lief es dagegen bei der
europa league in der zwischenrunde
trifft dortmund auf die glasgow rangers
leipzig spielt gegen real sociedad san
sebastian
so ist es module also hier geht's jetzt
weiter mit dem montagskino und das
verspricht spannend zu werden live
wettlauf gegen die zeit und direkt
danach gegen 23.45 meldet sich nah sein
möchte mir mit unserem heute-journal
update wir sehen uns morgen wieder
[Musik]
ein schoko nannte und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter mit hohem
luftdruck geht es zwar weiter aber
sonnenschein macht sich schon relativ
frei also über deutschland und über
mitteleuropa meist hoher luftdruck und
dann kommt etwas regen von nordwesten es
wird hauptsächlich sprühregen sein sowie
in der kommenden nacht im nordwesten
sonst dominieren meist zahlreiche wolken
ist es ziemlich trüb nach süden bildet
sich nebel und an den alpen da kann auch
mal die können sich mal die sterne
zeigen und die temperaturen sinken dort
auf -4 grad im südwesten auf null sonst
ist es aber frostfrei mit den mildesten
werten richtung nordsee mit plus 7 grad
ja und morgen im tagesverlauf weitere
dichte wolken teils etwas regen also
sprühregen hauptsächlich im süden
blinzelt mal die sonne hervor genauso
wie richtung schleswig holstein aber oft
ist es eben ein trüber tag mit höchsten
temperaturen von drei grad an den alpen
und 9 grad ganz im westen generell haben
wir es mit relativ milden werten zu tun
für die jahreszeit schauen wir auf die
aussichten am mittwoch im westen etwas
regen häufig trüb bisschen sonnenschein
es vielleicht nach südwesten und dem
nordwesten dabei vier bis zehn grad
donnerstag und freitag ist entweder
nebel angesagt etwas sonnenschein oder
dichte wolken das liegt eben an dem
hohen luftdruck und damit ein schöner
abend